يعني الواضح ان قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
تقوم بدفع المزيد من التعزيزات بدايه الى
هنا الى مدينه جنين ولكن قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ونتيجه هذه الاشتباكات قامت ب
تعطيل محول الكهرباء الرئيسي وكما ترين
عبر
عدسه الكاميرا ويرينا الان الزميل راجي ان
معظم انحاء واحياء مدينه جنين الرئيسيه
اصبحت في ظلام كامل لا يوجد كهرباء على
الاطلاق في كثير من الاحياء الرئيسيه خاصه
اننا هنا نتواجد
عند الدوار الرئيسي في وسط مدينه جنين
الاشتباكات المسلحه عنيفه لكنها متقطعه
بين الفينه والاخرى وفق شهود
عيان اذا كما تسمعين الاشتباكات يعني
متقطعه بين الفينه والاخرى واضح انه هناك
ايضا ووفق ما نراه هذا لا يمكن الا ان
يكون جيب عسكري يقوم باقتحام احد المحال
التجاريه واضح ان العمليه المتواصله
تستهدف بالفعل حتى هذه
اللحظه عدد
منس
ب يعني محلات الصرافه ولكن ماكن تواجد
الجيش في جنين هي تحديدا عند دوار
الداخليه السينما ومحيطها شارع البريد
شارع ابو بكر وايضا مناطق عده هناك مسيرات
كما نستطيع ان نسمعها في الخلفيه وعلى
ارتفاع منخفض في جنين ولكن ايضا في طول
كرم اي وا قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اي
وفق ما يردنا الان من مدينه طول كرم ان
هناك اقتحام لعماره في الحي الغربي بمدينه
طول كرم ومنع
سكان البنايه من الشقق السكنيه التنقل
وتقوم بتحطيم اعمال وتخريب بمنزل احد
اصحاب المحال التجاريه اذا يتم ليس فقط
تحطيم الابواب واقتحام المحلات الصرافه
لكن يتم ايضا التوجه الى منازل اصحاب هذه
المحل اقتحام منازلهم واقتيادهم سواء
لمحلاتهم التجاريه او الى مراكز اعتقال
وتحقيق في جني في طول كرم لوحدها ما وصلنا
انه ارتفع عدد المعتقلين العاملين بمحلات
الصرافه في مدينه طولكرم الى سته اما في
مدينه رام الله ايضا هناك لازالت اشتباكات
مسلحه متقطعه وايضا يبقى الهدف هو عدد من
محلات الصرافه الرئيسيه والتي لها فروع في
عديد من المدن الفلسطينيه يتم وضع ملصقات
على بعض ابواب هذه المحال التجاريه من
بينها
محلات الصرافه ويوضع شعار بان حماس تساوي
داعش وهذا هو الشعار الذي تحاول الترويج
له اي سلطات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي منذ هجوم
السابع من اكتوبر وبدء الحرب على غزه هذا
الترويج الدولي
ولعالم الغربي لكن واضح ان نظره العالم
بدات تتغير شيئا فشيئا بسبب صور المجازر
التي ترتكب في داخل قطاع غزه